Hey youtubers it's Charlie. HUGE NEWS, the BBC
just released "The Night of The Doctor".
The Mini-Episode chronicling how
Paul Mcgann turned into John Hurt, the dark
Doctor or "The Warrior" as he calls
himself.
I know originally I said I was going
to post my TOP 5 Doctor Who Villains but
this
is just so much cooler right now. I'll do a
breakdown first and I've also got
details on the 50th Anniversary livestream that we're doing with the BBC
America.
First I want to say thank you to BBC America
for sending me this giant TARDIS. I had
a little bobble head that I used to put in some of my videos, but I have been upgraded!
So high fives! Now to business. So "The Night
Of The Doctor"
chronicles the regeneration of Paul Mcgann into John Hurt.
Originally we'd heard that Paul Mcgann was
going to be part of the 50th
Anniversary in Mini-Episode content. But when I post that video it was
so long ago and we hadn't received any
confirmation between then and now, so
it was kind of a pipe dream and I thought I
was just a rumor. So the Doctor swoops
to save a woman from a gunship
crashing into the planet Karn.
He doesn't know her, but he is wearing a
costume that's really reminiscent the TV
movie as was the "Big Finish" stuff that
he's been doing recently.
She does recognize the TARDIS and you do
get a sense for how the rest of the
universe
views the Time Lords in this moment. They
basically hate them just as much they
hate the Daleks, just because they're
basically destroying everything in their
war.
The Doctor does say that he is a lover
not a fighter, but she doesn't care and
then end up crashing anyway.
We find out the Sisterhood of Karn knew that this was all probably going to happen
and that he was going to be the one to
end the Time War. We can talk about why
that is in the comments below just because
Karn has a big history in the Doctor
Who universe.
If you're not familiar with the Sisterhood,
They're the keepers at the Sacred Flame,
which is used to make the Elixir Of Life.
Which is within those goblets that the
women are holding in this episode.
It's basically used during
difficult regeneration. The interesting thing
here is that they present him
with all the colors the rainbow he could
be any kind a doctor he wants to be.
But he chooses to be a warrior because
the universe has no use for a Doctor right
now.
So this is where we confirmation that Paul
McCann regenerates into John Hurt. I
think there are a lot of theories about
where John Hurt fell in the Doctor Who
timeline. But I think we'd always kind of
sensed that he was the 8.5 Doctor.
He is part of the Doctor Who lineage
because he was born for regeneration.
He just did not call himself The Doctor, just
because I think The Doctor is kind of
a symbol of universal peace
or chaos depending on how you look at it.
So what did I think of the episode?
It was fantastic of course. Giant "A", I actually watched  it about four times to make sure I
wasn't missing anything.
it did an amazing job of explaining
what's going on in 50th Anniversary
episode.
That they're in the middle of the Time War and why he came to John Hurt Doctor.
I think that was really the main purpose
of the Mini-Episode, to explain why the
John Hurt Doctor was born.
I also really love the moment where he
basically said goodbye to all his friends
and previous companions.
He was basically saying that I have
something really awful that I have to do,
please forgive me.
The episode also looks amazing visually too.  You can't really tell it apart from any of the
other episodes the quality is so good.
The planet he's on is obviously the same
planet you see John Hurt on
in the 50th Anniversary Trailer. So
obviously part of the 50th
Anniversary episode will take place on
Karn.
I though it was interesting though that even
though he died in the crash with the
gunship,
the Sisterhood brought him back to life...
for 4 minutes only
Just for 4 minutes. Time enough to
choose a new flavor of Doctor.
But for those of you that saw my
previous video, I said
Jenna-Louise Coleman basically told us
that we would see a regeneration in the
50th Anniversary episode.
Obviously that is not going to be this
regeneration.
So that means that we will probably see
John Hurt regenerate into Christopher Eccleston.
I know he's technically physically
not in the 50th Anniversary episode.
But you know how they showed John Hurt basically in a reflection. They can use
Christopher Eccleston's
likeness. Because obviously they have to
chronicle the time between the end of
the Time War
and the time where The Doctor meets
Rose Tyler. But let me know what are your
reactions to "The Night Of The Doctor" and seeing this regeneration.
It's amazing to see Paul Mcgann as Doctor
Who in an official Doctor Who production,
it's so great. And if you've never seen
Paul Mcgann's Doctor before and you're
like a Matt Smith David Tennant fan
who hasn't seen a lot of Classic Who let
me know if you understand what's going
on in the story right now
because we can talk about it in the comments. Like I said I'll be doing tons more
Doctor Who videos for the 50th
Anniversary.
I'll be doing a Doctor Who Giveaway.
I'll be giving way Doctor Who 50th
Anniversary DVD's
starting tomorrow, so look for that video
tomorrow morning.
Big Thank You to Nerdist and BBC America
for sending me the giant TARDIS.
You can also look forward to the livestream
we'll be doing on November 23rd before
the 50th Anniversary episode.
That will start at 2:20 p.m. Eastern
Time
The 50th Anniversary will air at
2:50 p.m. Eastern Time
I'll be sure to post the link to the
livestream and all my videos
in the description as well as in the
comments whenever that happens.
So if you have any questions about the
50th Anniversary, what's happening or
the content I'm doing,
be sure to write in the comments. Right
now CLICK HERE to watch all my other
special 50th Anniversary videos
and CLICK HERE to learn all about Peter Capaldi's new Doctor. Thanks so much for
watching see you guys tonight
HIGH FIVES!